bienvenido al vídeo de fracciones
equivalentes y qué es eso de fracciones
equivalentes pues es tal cual lo que
suena o sea son dos fracciones que
aunque están escritas con otros números
representan la misma cosa a ver vamos a
ver un par de ejemplos para que quede
todo muy claro digamos que tenemos por
aquí un medio digamos que tenemos por
aquí un pastel y un medio del pastel
pues tomamos el pastel y lo dividimos a
la mitad y tomamos una sola de las
partes entonces en el denominador
tenemos un 2 así es que tenemos que
dividir al pastel en dos pedazos y en el
numerador tenemos nada más un 1 así es
que tenemos que tomar únicamente una de
las partes del pastel bueno pero ahora
qué pasa si el pastel lo dividimos entre
4 lo dividimos entre 2 y luego cada
mitad lo dividimos entre 2 y color hemos
exactamente la misma cantidad de pastel
entonces pues tenemos que colorear todo
esto no
esta parte del pastel si es igualita
esta no entonces qué fracción representa
a la parte coloreada de este pastel pues
a ver estamos dividiendo al pastel entre
4 así es que tenemos cuatro pedazos del
pastel y estamos coloreando dos de ellas
entonces en el numerador tenemos que
poner un 2 a ver pero estas fracciones
representan qué parte del pastel nos
estamos comiendo aunque parte del pastel
alguien se comió y si te fijas en estos
dibujos pues nos comimos exactamente la
misma cantidad de pastel no estos
dibujos llegó excepto por la forma en la
que partimos el pastel son exactamente
igualitos no nos comimos la misma
cantidad de pastel entonces estas dos
fracciones representan exactamente lo
mismo entonces si alguien llega y te
dice que se comió la mitad del pastel en
realidad se comió la misma cantidad de
pastel que alguien más que llegue y te
diga que se comió dos cuartas partes del
pastel
pero bueno vamos a seguir haciendo más
ejemplos digamos por ejemplo que tenemos
el pastel por acá pero que ahora no solo
lo dividimos entre cuatro sino que
además cada una de las cuatro rebanadas
las dividimos en la mitad o sea estamos
dividiendo el pastel en ocho partes
iguales ok
estamos dividiendo al pastel en ocho
partes iguales pero ahora nos vamos a
comer cuatro rebanadas del pastel ya
está 1 2 3 y 4
entonces otra vez nos estamos comiendo
la misma cantidad de pastel que en estos
otros dos pasteles no este dibujo
también es igualito a este otro dibujo
no a ver entonces nos estamos comiendo
cuatro rebanadas así es que en el
numerador tenemos que poner un 4 y como
la cantidad de pastel que estamos
comiendo es la misma entonces estas
fracciones que representan la cantidad
de pastel que nos estamos comiendo
también son igualitas pero bueno
ahora fijándonos únicamente en las
fracciones notas alguna especie de
secuencia oculta por allí está muy
bonito no o sea tenemos 124 en los
numeradores y en el denominador tenemos
24 y 8 bueno pues resulta que si hay
unas secuencias si hay una forma de
pasar de esta fracción a esta fracción
aunque si te fijas aquí para pasar de
este denominador a este denominador lo
único que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar por 2 y pasa exactamente lo
mismo en el numerador o sea para pasar
de 1 a 2 lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar por 2 a ver aquí en esta
onda de los pasteles pues lo que estamos
haciendo es dividir cada una de las
rebanadas del pastel en dos pedazos y
eso es equivalente a multiplicar el
denominador por 2 porque cada una de las
rebanadas ahora son 2 rebanadas y en el
numerador estamos multiplicando por 2
porque como hay el doble de rebanadas
entonces para comer la misma cantidad de
pastel pues tenemos que comer el doble
de rebanadas porque en este pastel cada
rebanada mide la mitad que en este
pastel no y aquí se ve muy claramente o
sea dos rebanadas del segundo pastel
son igualitas a una rebanada de este
pastel bueno para pasar de aquí a acá
pasa exactamente lo mismo cada una de
las rebanadas del pastel la estamos
dividiendo a la mitad o sea que estamos
multiplicando el denominador por 2 y
entonces para comer este pedazo del
pastel pues tenemos que comer el doble
de rebanadas así es que tenemos que
multiplicar el numerador por 2 y estas 3
fracciones son fracciones equivalentes
bueno entonces vamos a ver más ejemplos
ahora digamos que tenemos la fracción
tres quintos y lo que vamos a hacer para
construir una fracción que sea
equivalente a esta fracción es
multiplicar tanto el numerador como el
denominador por 7 aunque entonces en
realidad estamos multiplicando por la
fracción 7 entre 7 a mary eso lo que nos
queda es 3 por 7 21 entre 5 por 7 35
entonces tres quintos 3 puntos y 21 35 a
bosch son fracciones equivalentes ahora
lo que estamos haciendo no es magia ok
si es cierto que estos números no son
iguales a estos números pero las
fracciones en sí sí lo son
o sea representan la misma cantidad de
pastel
ok aquí lo que hicimos al multiplicar
por siete séptimos en realidad
séptimos es exactamente igual a 1 ok
aquí estamos multiplicando tres quintos
por uno pero este uno lo estamos
escribiendo en la forma de siete
séptimos ok y si te comes siete séptimos
de un pastel en realidad te estás
comiendo todo el pastel lo que hay por
eso es que multiplicar por uno nos deja
exactamente la misma fracción o el mismo
número pero bueno veamos otro ejemplo a
ver ahora digamos que tengo 52 sea vos
sin embargo quiero una fracción
equivalente a 512 a vos pero que en el
denominador tenga un 36
ok tengo mi pastel dividido en 12
pedacitos y me como 5 de ellos y ahora
quiero que tu pastel esté dividido en 36
pedacitos entonces si yo me voy a comer
5 rebanadas de mi pastel y tú y yo vamos
a comer exactamente la misma cantidad de
pastel cuántas rebanadas de pastel te
tienes que comer tú ese es el número que
tenemos que poner por aquí
y ese es el número que va a hacer que
estas dos fracciones sean equivalentes a
ver para pasar de 12 a 36 tenemos que
multiplicar 12 por 3 636 no entonces
tenemos que multiplicar por 3 y si
queremos que estas dos fracciones sean
equivalentes entonces tenemos que
multiplicar este numerador por 3 3 por 5
son 15 y listo 5 12 a 2 es igual a 15 36
a bosch y entonces decimos que estas dos
fracciones son equivalentes y que es lo
que nos está diciendo esto que si yo me
como 5 rebanadas del pastel que está
dividido en 12 pedacitos y tú te comes
15 rebanadas de un pastel que esté
dividido en 36 pedacitos entonces tú y
yo vamos a comer exactamente la misma
cantidad de pastel y esa es la clave con
las fracciones equivalentes o sea dos
fracciones son equivalentes
si puedes pasar de una a
multiplicando el numerador y el
denominador por exactamente el mismo
número bueno espero que todo haya
quedado muy claro